this season was so much fun it was
pretty wild
i want to start with you asa
otis and maeve shared not one but two
kisses this season they admitted that
they wanted to be together and then she
just took off for the usa
what does i know
what does their future look like in your
mind in my mind i don't really don't
know funny i haven't thought i haven't
been able to talk about any of this
they've both still got a lot to learn
and who knows what may will discover in
america they're both so young
i mean it's it's like
who the hell knows i really don't i feel
like if i predict it it's just gonna go
the opposite way so i'm not gonna say
anything there's someone called maeve
and she's really important to me
i know i don't really understand
anything about love
i think she's my person well she does
say
see you soon this isn't goodbye
would you ever like to see a full-blown
relationship between otis
and maeve he did tell his mom that she's
his person i would like to see it
even if it doesn't work out in the end i
mean they are young
it probably won't but i'm interested to
see what would happen when all of this
kind of
not tension but a bit of expectation
and they are
inherently kind of
connected and attracted to each other's
personalities um
so who knows but yeah i'd like to see at
least what happens our investors have
pulled all of their funding from the
school
so we have no choice but to sell more
dale secondary to developers more dale
is shut down what does that mean for the
students and for potential season four
mimi we'll start with you on this one
you know what it's a really good
question i would love to know the answer
too
but i don't i
said you don't know the answer to that
do you
no
no i mean i
i see we're not finished in school we
still need somewhere to go to school
right is that the case we'll have to
either find a new school yeah i suppose
we need to find a new school i have no
idea but i hope we carry on all together
i hope we don't all get separated maybe
they'll get a job maybe they'll do some
more adult things
maybe they'll find a new college to go
to i've yeah i really don't know i don't
know if it will be a new college i feel
like it's got to be a bigger shake up
than that because i feel like then if
you're going to start in a new school
then it's sort of going back to the
beginning whereas i think if there's
another season it's got to progress some
way and i think leaving school is a good
way to do that yeah and figuring out how
they leave school that age we allow so
we're old enough to leave school
yes
okay i changed my answer we'll probably
leave school
okay so
i hope so that would be fun i liked your
answer mimi we got to see a lot of
realness movie between last season and
and this season and some development
where would you like to see that
character potentially
girl i think i like to see her becoming
more of a team player
which i think that we've we've kind of
explored like towards the end with um
sort of her
trying to save the
performance i guess that the school has
put together and getting into i suppose
it's a fight yeah
mistress yeah i mean it's a bold move
from ruby you know she doesn't usually
care about other people or what's going
on she's cared about herself i think the
audience seemed more of a an emotional
side to her and seeing who she is on the
inside behind the uh sort of hard
exterior that she's shown in the
previous seasons i think just to carry
on down that route and just see her be
more comfortable
showing who she really is and yeah just
being uh being more of a team player i
think would be would be great to see
that in her asa i can't help but feel
that otis has somehow gotten
i want to say cooler but i don't feel
like that's the right word maybe more
angsty in season three
was that super intentional otis's
journey wasn't it never goes in the
direction i expect it to
uh season three was no exception um i
don't think anyone anticipated him and
ruby becoming a thing but it was cool
because it gave me the opportunity to do
something a bit different and explore
uh a different side of the character
which is always
exciting as an actor
and i think he's grown up a lot he's got
some confidence he's got a bit of spring
in his step
ruby's definitely
brought some of that out of him brought
out some sassiness which is very funny
he's gone from being someone that nobody
really knows in the classroom to being
possibly one of the most respected
students on the campus so
i don't know anything's possible how do
you feel though about all the attention
that the show has brought with people to
you have you learned to embrace it is it
ever
it's it's kind of mad netflix
i suppose just does that the nature of
platform being
everywhere around the world and whenever
you need it whenever you want it
and the show was a massive hit and so
those two things combined does mean
we do get kind of catapulted into this
very much in the public eye
and that's cool that the show does so
well but i mean it definitely has some
drawbacks in terms of kind of
exposure and i tend to keep to myself
and i try to and i'm pretty low-key
and that's
getting harder to do and that's just the
nature of it i mean that's that's a part
of this industry there's two sides to it
it's amazing to have such a response and
here's a lot so many lovely things from
people and i'm generally pretty good at
not letting it
get too too overwhelming
yeah i mean i've been doing this a long
time now so i've i'm somewhat used to it
you did say in an interview that you
would be okay if season three was the
end
but because there are so many
cliffhangers in season three
do you really feel like that could have
been the end like what are your guys's
overall hopes for a potential
season four i think i'd like to do
another season i think it'll be nice to
have a real resolute ending yeah um
but at the same time i think this
leaving it more open-ended i wouldn't be
upset if they if they if they called it
f3 uh i feel like we have seen a lot of
these characters
so i don't mind either way it'd be fun
to explore some more and explore them in
a different saying but
it's out of our hands
yeah
not up to us but i probably would like
to uh
i probably would like to uh yeah see
what happens but that's me as a person
you know i'm a kind of impatient i
always want to know i always want a
definite answer so for me yes
yes i'm with you i want to know what
happens okay good
of course gene gave birth in the finale
so otis has a little sister but
the dna results seem to have shocked her
what does that
oh my god
yeah i don't even know he said what does
that mean
it means
who's the dad
does it mean who's the dad i don't know
i don't know what it means i mean
there's a few things that come in it
sounds like you read into it it means
more drama is what it means to be
open-ended it's never it's never easy on
sex education it's never simple hey so
this is getting too open-ended now we
need some answers do you think otis will
be a good big brother
yeah i think he's learning he's i
definitely think in season three he's
come to accept that side of himself and
try and try and be a role model
yeah
jillian anderson is so iconic how is it
working side by side with her for for so
long now
it's been so much fun yeah julian i
think she i think she has a lot of fun
playing gene and you can really see that
we just sort of bounced off of that
energy and
we have a real great rapport i think at
this point um in this kind of mother's
son dynamic um
and uh yeah she she brings a lot to the
show
you